I'm Cara Santa Maria for Wired I'm here
with Dan Harmon and Justin roiland the
co-creators of Rick and Morty so this is
a new animated series that's going to be
on Adult Swim so what's it about
uh it's about a sociopathically
alcoholically ingenious scientist who
can accomplish anything with his mind
and his less than genius grandson who he
takes on these crazy adventures run
morning rod
so I less than genius you mean like way
like like any any anything that held you
back in school like or anyone that you
know more DS got it okay he's flunking
out of school I mean he's he's not dumb
in the sense that that he literally has
no thoughts of his own I mean he
certainly fights back and yells a trick
and there's a there's certainly a
dynamic to their relationship but he is
dumb in the sense that he's failing
school he uh he's not the brightest bulb
in the bulb
peccable package that's that's what's
raised I mean it's hard to tell that at
first glance because bulb packages they
they're all they're all inert I mean
they're not plugged into yeah you can't
even yeah I come in the pack so you have
to go through the be end like screw him
in and then you know Morty is not the
brightest yeah he's not the brightest
yeah he's getting taken here and there
by his insane grandfather on all these
crazy sci-fi adventures and put in
harm's way Rick never really seems to be
too worried about that it's it's sort of
a fun dynamic where Morty is is is is
constantly being just thrust into
insanity and in his little is like this
is this is crazy and he's freaking out
and Rick's kind of like you know don't
worry about it Morty it's all good just
get me the give me my peanuts inside
that guy's you know left testicle or
whatever it's grabbing my favorite
episode setting you know it's not a real
episode that's not a real to the pilot
not on a federal episode the
foundational like a level of the show is
so grounded the way in is a it's like a
fox show I mean it's a family there's a
mom and a dad it's Chris Parnell plays
the dad and Ciroc plays the mom and
they're either they're credible and they
have a whole they have a whole
relationship dynamic that is very fresh
and it's sort of their marriage is just
just hanging on by a thread and there's
all that is it's all there to really
welcome the audience in to a really low
concept but you know just okay I know
what this is I'm familiar with this and
then from there Rick Burton it goes
Morty you got to come to the garage
Morty I need your help you got it you
got to do something
me morning and morning oh geez Rick I
don't want to do it and my voice is all
screwed up but you know it's it's and
then we're just cutting back between
this insanity that Rick is taking Morty
on and and then and then this very
grounded sort of really incredibly
well-written thanks to this dude a
marriage falling apart and just these
conversations that the wife and and and
and and husband or mom and dad are
having really looking forward to seeing
Rick and Morty and again tell people how
they can see it it'll be on Adult Swim
in December look for it you'll hear
about it